I am Dr nandor fodorp the world's
foremost parapsychologist I am not a
skeptic this is the strangest case I
ever had a family living in Farmhouse
claim a talking Mongoose lives in their
Barn creature's name is Jeff
what do you think about it
attacking Mongoose the urban family are
peculiar Did You observe this creature
no no I did hear it we are going to the
Isle of Man I have almost 20 years of
research in this field
is the creature here well because we
can't see him doesn't mean he ain't here
I see
her daughter is the ventriloquist
[Music]
this is an inexplicable Force
and say the way Rascal is probably
watching us right now everybody on this
island has their Jeff story tell me
yours you and I both know
right now
[Music]
can you tell him to come out so he can
see him
is that him there what I guess the
Irving's motive didn't strike me as con
artists
we're here with our eyes as much as we
do Aries these people are lying I think
he exists I'm certain of it
just show yourself I mean
I mean you harm
show me that you're real
[Music]
there's a call for you this is from him
hello
[Music]